this is Startalk this is from Nelson saw
mm-hmm Nelson says what are some of the
most important non space related
advances which came directly or mostly
from research at NASA Oh
NASA is fully focused on space so maybe
the way to answer this is there are
advances that directly helped space and
things we were doing in space and other
things that not only help space but then
help what we did here on earth maybe
that's the way to answer this but NASA's
not researching how to make your better
cup of coffee but they do utilize
technology and technological advances it
is always with the mission of trying to
improve our duration time technology in
space mm-hmm but that doesn't mean it
can't apply to very cool things on earth
for example go ahead something simple
ready go ahead lately if you have taken
the exit ramp over of most highways and
if that exit ramp has a pretty tight
turn the pavement is grooved it is have
you noticed I have noticed that okay
that came from NASA and why exactly
would that come from NASA because the
last time I checked space is there were
no off ramp
yeah I'm just lucky area okay as I
understood this when it was told to me
the you have the Space Shuttle coming in
for a landing and it's not the space
shuttles a glider coming in all right
this back when we actually put people in
space how sad okay so but in the day way
back right
remember when as Bill Nye likes to do is
he's always puts on his old man voice
when he sorry way back in the day you go
back and when we flew space shuttles
when you come back to earth and you're
going to land you're landing a glider
right all right there's hardly any
control over your you know you have air
limb flaps and things but you're a
glider
now suppose it's raining or there's it's
a little wet okay you don't want the
things sliding to the left and the right
so you put grooves in the pavement which
help a lot
the wheels in the direction the wheel is
rotating which is the direction the road
points right there you have it and so
this reduced the possibility of skidding
and people realize hey why don't we put
that on all France because they'll car
if you're going too fast and you come
off the ramp you're hitting the
embankment right ok so now you can ask
here's the fascinating point you can say
why spend the millions of dollars or
whatever it took to good why not just
have somebody invent that right outright
why okay because no one did
however cheap you think that is right
the fact is that solution only came
about when someone cared about space
right and it turns out when you going I
have found you go into space people
gather around who care about that right
smart people who care about that right
and those are the problems they want to
solve you're not gonna go to the
smartest person in the room and say oh
can you help me prevent cars from
skidding off the off-ramp of the
interstate 95 we'll see there's also no
money and that what you that last point
right well yeah hey help me stop cars
from skidding off that yeah well what's
in it right and what why should I help
you do that and I'm at the top of my
class why am I gonna do that but if I
instead say prevent the Space Shuttle
after coming out of orbit from skidding
on its runway you're gonna figure this
stuff out right so space exploration has
a way of infusing levels and dimensions
of creativity and anybody who thinks
about it and that's how you get these
amazing solutions to everyday life oh
man that is a great great point I'm not
even calling them spin-offs because the
spinoff would be we got this widget in
space now you use the widget on earth
now it's not even about that
no no these are I mean some of these are
direct applications just because they as
you fudge as you see with the grooves
you find use for it somewhere else and
it's extremely important to have uh you
can't think of how many thousands of
lives probably have been saved by people
having grooves at that simple little
thing that's simple and no one writes a
story about the life that was not taken
so true yeah I know yeah which is why I
often contemplate suicide Oh Chuck I'm
joking I'm joking but it
just it was hanging there I had to say
Maddox
hey well that was a great question
Nelson and just remember that NASA will
continue to suffer budget cuts just
figure that though that it just just say
oh wait let me give you one more just
one more example okay so the docking
algorithms to get the space shuttle to
dock with the space station right there
are two sort of collars that come
together right and there's a laser
stabilizing system that enables that to
happen right and this software related
to that and the like I say right as in
I'm sure you're right amazing right as
in yes you're correct I guys I already
knew that exactly so so what we found is
that the surgery used to cut your cornea
have it real to adjust your vision which
would correct LASIK lasik surgery I well
we didn't always use lasers okay hey B
so so now that it uses lasers how do you
do that to someone if they're I might
jiggle a little bit while you're trying
to cut right okay that's not what you
want there's notes you don't want some
things you want to jiggle I and I and a
cutting at Sears circumcision right okay
so so what they've done was adapted this
laser stabilizing mechanism that allowed
the cut to move with the moving eyeball
in case the moving eyeball moved and
it's from the docking mechanism of the
space shuttle in the space station so so
this NASA technology enabled this laser
lasik surgery to be conducted safer and
more cheaply than ever before yeah
that's why all of a sudden everybody
started getting it absolutely because of
its because it came out of space ah
that's a man not the concept for the
surgery no but just the together from
the surgery came from an accident that a
guy had and cut his eye no honestly the
design the healed knee was like okay I
don't know why but I could see better
you know and but yeah I could imagine
let me try it on you exactly Jason with
the kitchen knife yeah I can see better
cuz I cut my eye I should try to cut
your eye I bet you I could heal you but
uh that's that's fantastic mm-hmm
so that's an example of
so two extremes of examples one where
vision has been improved the other your
driving has been improved yeah right and
that both of them came out of the space
program yes it happens all the time
that's amazing that's a Nelson great
question man
great question this is Startalk